what's going on guys today i'll be going
over some of the details you might have
missed
in chapter 284 of my hero academia
including why afrodeku is now 100
canon if you're new to the channel i've
been doing these breakdowns for the last
couple weeks so be sure to like
subscribe if you'd like to see me do
them more often
also shout out to all of the patreon
gang especially trey cash and chronos gw
your support is immense and i really do
appreciate it
okay so moving on to the breakdown the
first interesting thing to note in this
chapter
is the state of deku's left side when
everything begins
currently his left arm is holding all
the pro heroes using blackwhip
but if you remember a couple of chapters
ago this same arm gave shiguraki
two separate smashes at one hundred
percent of one for all
so i mean it's already been established
that midoriya can use about 30
consistently so once all the adrenaline
wears off and you know everything cools
down
he is 100 screwed his right arm was
already messed up after his battle with
muscular
so i'm really concerned that by the end
of you know his time at ua
he's just not going to have any limbs
left because of the amount of stress
that he's put on his body
black whip starts to spaz out and he
lowers the good guys back down to earth
and i found it quite funny how endeavour
thinks that he should be the one up
there fighting shigeraki right now
don't get me wrong like obviously he's
the number one hero but
he began the day fighting the nomus in
the hospital and then he fought the
high-end nomus in the lab
before fighting shigeraki himself and
then chasing shiguraki down
and fighting him again like dude it's
okay to take a break
bakago shows some genuine concern for
deku in this moment
because you know as i explained now it's
just midoriya and shigaraki
alone together in the sky when in
reality
deku should be the furthest person away
from the villain given that
shiguraki's entire goal is just to steal
one for all
however izuku rightly points out that no
one else can keep shigaraki off the
ground
i mean the other flying heroes right
they're either on the verge of death or
they're injured or
really exhausted so he does have a valid
point
not to mention that even if the other
flying heroes
were healthy and fit none of them have a
long range quirk like black whip
which enables deku to kind of keep
shigeraki at arm's length
and not get decayed we get this awesome
panel of our two main characters
hurtling towards each other in the sky
and deku's left arm is being held
together by black whip at this point
meanwhile the right side of shigaraki's
body isn't doing too well
either as he's still suffering from the
effects of being woken up early
though stick around till the end of the
video because you'll see a big
difference between
his injuries now and his injuries at the
end of the chapter
moving on the manga flashes back to a
character
who i never thought i'd see i'd love to
tell you that afrodeku had some
dramatic backstory you know maybe he was
a failed cloning attempt
or perhaps deku's secret twin brother
but in reality he is just the result
of bakago letting off explosions
directly in midoriya's face
the two of them had been playing a game
during training in which deku had to try
and catch bakugou with blackwhip
however due to midoriya losing every
time omit arranged for him to train with
cerro ochaco
and froppy instead one detail that lets
us know when this training is taking
place
is when all might says that izawa is
currently busy and so he can't help deku
with his black whip technique
in his panel we see kirigiri who is
locked up in tartarus
and so this strongly implies that this
training occurred on the same day we
found out that kurugiri
is isawa's childhood best friend this
brings us to a very interesting piece of
trivia
about the title of this chapter but
first let me explain a little bit of
context
way back in chapter 253 the students had
just arrived back from their winter
break
and were about to show off what they'd
learned however izawa was abruptly
called to the staff room
and had to leave which is obviously then
when he went to tartarus prison
it wasn't until three chapters later
that we saw the students new moves
in a chapter titled high deep blue sky
in this chapter deku uses black whip in
mid-air
to pull these robots towards him before
finishing them off with a deadly kick
by comparison the title of chapter 284
is deep blue battle in which deku
shigaraki ensnared by blackwhip
and proceeds to kick straight through
him after the training flashback is over
this parallel is something i thought was
a cool easter egg and horukoshi had
clearly been plotting this many months
ago
by showing us the potential of what deku
could do and then finally executing it
on a villain
as i said in my spoiler review for this
chapter ochako makes deku float
which gets him more accustomed to the
sensation and in the words of all might
it could actually lead to him unlocking
his third quirk
meanwhile froppy acts like a target for
deku to catch with blackwhip
while cerro helps midoriya with his
posture and his form
whilst bakugou and all might chill
together kachan raises the very valid
point
that people won't be fooled forever once
deku keeps manifesting new quirks
i've previously mentioned the same thing
because float
is not just something that you could say
is the same quirk as black whip or one
for all
if i was a member of class 1a i start to
suspect that all might's close
connection to deku is something to do
with
all for one even bakugou himself made
that same connection in season three
so i see more of class 1a starting to
realize this
bakugou then goes on to mention how
despite deku trusting all might
the former symbol of peace is still
hiding things about one's rule from them
especially regarding the fourth user i
did a theory video about this exact
topic a few days ago
so i highly recommend you check that out
also i have one more thing to add to
this theory that i
didn't mention in the original video so
i may as well mention it now
and that is that we've seen that black
whip only activated
when deku was trying to capture someone
and likewise float only activated
when deku was trying to keep shigaraki
off the ground so
clearly the quirks inside one for all
they only appear when the relevant
emotion or desire
is present and so in the case of decay
that type of quirk would only manifest
if deku genuinely had killing intentions
like he wanted to
truly murder someone if all might is
hiding the secret of decay
then that would be based on a trust and
confidence in deku
that he won't be trying to kill anyone
anytime soon naturally all might could
not have foreseen that
deku would be in a life or death battle
with shigeraki right now
so maybe you know he didn't anticipate
this but
again when it comes to one for all
quirks don't manifest
until the emotion is relevant anyway
the chapter ends with bakugou admitting
how his arrogance
led him to bully deku which is clearly
now something that he regrets
an interesting line from all might was
how bakugo and endeavour are pretty
similar
in that they never took a moment to look
at their own behavior
until a big change happened to their
rival in endeavour's case
he didn't look at himself until all
might became the skeleton man that he is
today
and in bakago's case he didn't have a
look either until deku became what he's
becoming
because bakago does feel regret for the
way he's treated deku
that is partly why he's helping deku
with his training and trying to
master all these new quirks in my
opinion the similarities between bakugou
and endeavour
extend well beyond what all might
mentioned because i mean just for an
example
their demeanor like the way they present
themselves is quite off-putting to
regular people
not to mention of course that they both
have quirks that are quite explosive and
fiery
and they're both destined to be second
place to users of one for all it's just
an inevitable fact
that they will never surpass the people
that they're desperate to surpass
the chapter goes back to the present day
with bakago dragging endeavor to go and
help deku which implies that
next chapter we're gonna get some kind
of flash fire attack that will be
intended to finish shigaraki off deku
then kickshigaraki in the stomach
as i mentioned earlier in the video and
we get this sick panel of him
maneuvering through the air using float
and then he kind of admits that his left
arm is completely wrecked
but then goes in for one final punch
with his right arm
i just gotta say sugaraki does not look
pleased at how things are progressing
but he takes yet another punch to the
gut which is very similar to
a few chapters ago when endeavour gave
shiguraki the vanishing fist attack
but even in that situation shiggy was
still able to remain
conscious despite all his quirks being
erased so i'm not too sure
how much of an impact deku's punch is
gonna have here but we will see
if we compare the wound on sugaraki's
right side at the beginning of the
chapter
to the end of the chapter his super
regeneration is still very much working
it's still
you know doing its job but in deku's
words he's healing at a slower rate
but still i'm not sure how much of an
impact one punch will have
hopefully it could at least knock him
unconscious because if that could happen
then i think shiguraki's body would
still regenerate but he would still be
unconscious
that's the desired situation at this
point but whether it will happen
highly unlikely but we shall see those
were some of the details that you might
have missed
in my academia chapter 284 i hope you
all enjoyed it and i will see you
in the next one